et c'est parce que vous savez on est de
tous les partis et de loin celui qui
connaît la plus forte croissance quelque
chose qu'on a pas vu au Québec dans
l'histoire politique récente on a les
trois autres parties de position ont
décliné on est le seul parti qui a connu
une croissance ce soir et pour ça je
vous remercie chacune et chacun des
conservateurs qui ont mis leur sa bonne
place vous savez
au moment où je vous parle on a très
exactement le même nombre de votes que
le Parti libéral du Québec mais il
manque 20 députés à un comparé à l'autre
et c'est sûr on est on est on est d'une
certaine façon le prix avec une
distorsion démocratique du siècle comme
celle de voir la semaine dernière et bon
ça on va falloir qu'on en parle un peu
plus un peu plus tard mais c'est évident
que faut pas regarder ça faut pas non
plus être trop pessimiste ce soir moi je
me souviens que quand Québec soldat a
commencé sa première élection et on fait
moins de 4% puis tout le monde se péter
bretelles disait comment c'était
extraordinaire quand l'Action
démocratique a commencé avec Mario
Dumont je me rappelle que c'était 6.5
pour cent du vote aujourd'hui le moment
où on se parle c'est quoi 13% puis si la
fin de la soirée ça va continuer à
monter donc
je suis très confiant je suis très
content de vous
c'était une bataille de David qu'on
Goliath vous savez comme moi qu'on avait
pas une fraction des ressources de nos
adversaires quand j'ai pris au début
quand j'ai annoncé ma mon intention me
présenter à la direction du parti au
moins deux ans c'est un parti qui
comptait 500 membres qui était un
pourcent dans les intentions de vote
regardez on peut regarder ce qui nous
reste à faire avant d'atteindre le
pouvoir mais on peut aussi regarder tout
le chemin qu'on a parcouru ensemble à
gang depuis deux ans
la première étape où je dirais là je
devrais dire même la promesse
au fur et à mesure mais vous mettre
derrière moi vous avez tout fait des
routes extraordinaires
vous savez la politique c'est comme
notre sport national c'est comme là ok
il y a trois périodes la première
période pour nous autres à se termine ce
soir la première période c'était de
s'assurer de devenir un grand parti de
faire partie de la cour des grands et ça
on l'a accomplit de façon magistrale
bon la première période c'est même mieux
passer personnellement que ce que je
pensais qu'elle allait arriver je ne
pensais pas qu'on allait participer au
débat des chefs qu'on allaite de toutes
les grandes entrevues qu'on allait être
invité à tous les grands événements on a
vraiment été partout et que ce soir on
finirait pratiquement sur un pied
d'égalité de les quatre parties de
position mais surtout ce qui me rend le
plus fier je pense que notre plus grand
accomplissement au cours des dernières
semaines c'est d'avoir permis de
débattre d'idées qui se sont retrouvés
au centre de la campagne électorale
c'est parce qu'observateur avait pas été
là vous pouvez être certain qu'il aurait
pas été question de la contribution puis
de l'addition du secteur privant santé
c'est parce conservateur avait pas été
là vous êtes certain qu'on aurait pas
parlé de la liberté de choix des parents
en éducation pour les services de garde
de leurs enfants c'est parce qu'on
conservateur avait pas été là il y
aurait pas été question de relancer le
projet GNL Québec au Saguenay si parce
conservateur avait pas été là on
n'aurait pas parlé l'exploitation
responsable de nos hydrocarbures sur le
territoire québécois c'est conservateur
avait pas été là on aurait pas parlé des
cachotteries de François Legault sur le
troisième bien on n'aurait pas parlé de
l'inutile de l'inutile tramway à Québec
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de choses
qu'on a vu qu'on a réussi à mettre au
coeur des engagements politiques au
Québec et c'est grâce à la présence du
Parti conservateur dans tous les débats
je vous en remercie du fond du cœur vous
avez fait avancer le débat d'idée au
Québec bravo et
je vais vous remercier les militants
conservateurs parce que vous avez été
les plus motivés les plus souriants les
plus dynamiques tout au long de la
campagne électorale vous avez permis 4
rassemblements de plus de 1000 personnes
il y a pas un parti qui est arrivé à
acheter de tout ça vous avez permis 30
rassemblements on aura semblé au total
plus de 12000 personnes pendant cette
campagne électorale là c'est vrai plus
c'est vous vous êtes vraiment
extraordinaire
[Applaudissements]
je suis fier de votre dynamisme je suis
fier de vos sourires vos poignées de
main me donnent de l'énergie m'en donne
encore à soi ça me permet d'être
optimiste d'être de bonne humeur ce soir
ça c'est grâce à vous merci du fond du
cœur je veux je veux aussi vous parler
de la deuxième période parce qu'il va
avoir une deuxième période évidemment
qui va devoir avoir lieu puis cette
deuxième période là va commencer le même
matin d'ici la prochaine campagne
électorale on a des bases on a des
assises importantes on a fini deuxième
dans plusieurs régions dans plusieurs
circonscriptions ce soir on est on a des
organisations maintenant dans toutes les
circonscriptions on va avoir du
financement public quand même auteur que
les autres parties d'opposition ce qu'on
avait pas jusqu'à maintenant et donc
on a semé de l'espoir de l'espoir depuis
plusieurs mois dans le cadre et dans la
tête de bien des Québécois là ça va être
le temps de commencer à consolider tout
ça on va en plus de temps pour mieux
s'organiser c'est sûr qu'on était dans
une courte période de temps un parti qui
avait pas de ressources de temps plus de
monde plus de ressources moi j'ai
confiance que la deuxième personne la
deuxième période on va se battre pas mal
plus avec armégal on va permettre à
David parce que notre combo oublié le
pas c'est le combat de David contre
Goliath on va permettre à David de
s'entraîner pendant 4 ans tout en
s'assurant qu'on va fragiliser les pieds
du Goliath tranquillement comment ça
s'effriter de bonnes autres ok on va
évidemment la troisième période mais la
troisième période vous la connaissez
toutes ça va être la prochaine campagne
électorale je vous l'ai dit dès le début
je l'ai dit depuis le 22 novembre 2020
quand j'ai annoncé mon intention de
briguer la direction du Parti
conservateur je serai encore là la
prochaine campagne électorale ça c'est
clair net et précis OK
on va frapper à plus de portes on va
semer encore plus d'espoir
merci
écoutez mais moi aussi je vous aime je
vous adore vous savez pas comment j'ai
eu du plaisir à aller à votre rencontre
depuis deux ans vous avez été la plus
belle expérience de humaine de ma vie
j'en serai jamais trop reconnaissant on
est parti avec une claque une bottine
qu'on a fait ce que personne ne fait
dans l'histoire politique récente au
Québec c'est grâce à chacune et chacun
d'entre vous puis avoir besoin de vous
autres encore plus au cours des quatre
prochaines années pour consolider puis
agrandir ce mouvement là OK
je veux terminer évidemment
en félicitant nos adversaires parce que
les Québécois ont choisi de continuer
nous autres on a choisi de continuer à
les avoir à l'oeil puis aller surveiller
et donc on va on va aller dans cette
direction-là je veux quand même
féliciter mon adversaire ici Sylvain les
vagues je vais féliciter François
Legault je vais féliciter tous les
autres 123 députés qui ont été élus ce
soir je pensais important de le faire
mais je leur dis préparez-vous parce que
dans 4 ans ça va être pas mal du coffre
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]